the fact is that organisms are never
perfectly suited to their environment
the way evolution works is through a
whole series of compromises and
jury-rigged solutions based on what was
there before hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
Friesen TV and today we're talking with
Marlene Zuk she's an evolutionary
biologist at the University of Minnesota
and the author of the new book paleo
fantasy Marley and thanks for talking to
us thanks for having me the idea the
Paleo diet and mimicking the cavemen
like lifestyle has picked up a lot of
steam lately and you're seeing the basis
for these ideas is missing the mark so
could you go into that a little bit and
some of the evolutionary examples that
support this I've gotten really
interested in the last few years in how
much we now can understand about the
rate of evolution and it turns out that
we now can understand that evolution
acts quickly under some circumstances
and slowly under others and that then
made me interested in this whole idea
that humans are mismatched with their
environment because we evolved under a
certain set of circumstances that we've
now deviated from and so therefore we're
in bad shape because we're not eating
the way people did a hundred thousand
years ago we're not interacting with
each other the way people did a hundred
thousand years ago we're not exercising
the way we did a hundred thousand years
ago and so forth and I think that that
idea just overlooks a lot of really cool
stuff that's been happening in evolution
one of your points is that the cavemen
had a lot longer time to adapt to their
surroundings than we have to modern life
with cities and our environment so how
does this play a role it's absolutely
true that our bodies didn't evolve under
circumstances where we had television
and lots of calorie rich but nutrient
poor food but at the same time talking
about life a hundred thousand years ago
like it was completely static or like it
was the same all over the world doesn't
reflect reality either because things
were changing then as well so I think we
tend to have nostalgia about lots of
things whether it's our own childhoods
or life in the 1950s or you know maybe
life in the Stone Age but the fact is
that organisms are never perfectly
suited to their environment the way
evolution works is through a whole
series of compromises and jury-rigged
solutions based on what was there before
and it's not like organisms evolve
evolve evolve and then get to a point
and go oh Hugh we've now done it we're
perfect everything is exactly in tune
with the environment and we can now stop
and anything that happens that moves us
off this peak is going to be to our
detriment and that wasn't true a hundred
thousand years ago and it's also not
true now so you wouldn't say that
technology has outpaced us as far as
evolving biologically the question of
the degree to which you can separate our
biology from our culture is something
that anthropologists and biologists have
talked about for a long time and I don't
think it's an easy one I don't think you
can put them into these separate bins we
can demonstrate that the genes have to
be able to digest dairy have actually
changed extremely recently over the last
five to seven thousand years so that
when people started cultivating cattle
they were able to use milk as a source
of both nutrients and potentially as
water this is what some people have
suggested that the selection was not
just to use the nutrients in milk but
because it's an uncontaminated source of
fluid which can be in short supply
depending on on your environment people
who happen to have a genetic variant
that allowed them to digest milk passed
weaning survived and left more copies of
their genes herding cattle is a part of
our culture it's a behavior so did that
technology outpace what people were able
to eat well not really it evolved
together with it you can argue that the
iPad is maybe a little bit faster than
cattle herding in that regard but it's a
matter of degree rather than kind and so
I think you want to be careful about
separating this out and saying oh we've
somehow got this primordial human that
could exist independent of technology or
culture or whatever you want to call it
because humans don't work that way we're
we're intertwined with our culture and
it's part of us are we still living in a
society that's built on survival for the
fittest and if you had to guess what
would be the next step for us so I think
the question about the next step is one
that assumes something about evolution
that isn't actually the case namely that
we're going
somewhere and so one of the things that
I often have a hard time getting across
is that evolution does precede and sort
of fits and starts and it'll depend on
the environment that we're in so
predicting this is it's almost like oh
we'll predict where we're going next
suggest that well step one is followed
by step 2 followed by step 3 and then
eventually we're going to end up as like
giant brains and jars or you know
whatever the science fiction has and
there's no reason to think that that's
going to happen I always see those
cartoons of you know the the fish
morphing into the amphibian that then
crawls onto the land and then you know
the reptile standing on four legs and
then you have you know usually the the
monkey and you know then eventually the
person it's such a misrepresentation for
the way evolution actually works which
isn't progressing toward anything
amphibians weren't trying to become
people and we're not trying to become
brains in jars style Marlene thanks so
much for talking - sure yeah this is fun
phrasing TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer